ce qui s'appelle marine j'ai pris son
portefeuille dans la rue hier soir je
lui fis comme ça ça s'appelle alors oui
en fait j'ai trouvé le portefeuille de
marie andrieu dans la rue hier soir j'ai
cherché ses nuits dans les pages
blanches où vous auriez son portable
je vous remercie d'être venus jusqu'ici
attention mari je vous conseille de ne
pas chercher à le roi pardon elle est
dangereuse
je me remémorais à de nombreuses
reprises
le moment précis où j'avais découvert
sans savoir jusqu'où cette expédition
allait m'amener
tu vas pas me croire j'ai suivi marine
sur l'île de groix votre ami est en
danger
en direction de lille avec l'ancien ami
de la fille tu as unis
jazz à gauche vous êtes un type très
bizarre s'est pas immédiatement
sympathique
enfin souvent l'amour toi non c'est quoi
ce truc
on dirait un mélange entre ce chanteur
biz areva elle
c'est fascinant 3 sur cette île marie
dans les environs quelle sera l'issue de
ce voyage
alors j'en ai mis une de la chambre dans
la cuisine le salon tu vois comme dans
paranormal activity
je vais pas sauter bien surtout noms du
genre je serais pas là